ce sont les seuls restaurants autorisés
à accueillir des clients depuis une
dizaine de jours les restaurants
routiers peuvent de nouveau fonctionner
en indre et loire deux d'entre eux ont
reçu l'aval de la préfecture pour
reprendre partiellement leurs activités
ils sont quatre en loir et cher romain
delville s'est rendu au relais des
platanes situés sur la rn10 à usseau en
bosse entre 18 heures et 10 heures du
matin l'établissement ne peut servir que
les professionnels du transport routier
lieu mythique de la rn 10 depuis 1955 le
relais routier les platanes peut garder
sa salle de restaurant ouverte le soir
alors donc en plage et choucroute garnie
poitrine de veau farcie filets de perche
sauce nantaise une lettre ou une
assiette froide de jambon but d'ozil en
france 250 relais comme celui ci on peut
rouvrir leur restaurant 4 en loir et
cher
c'est seulement de 18 heures à 10 heures
du matin pour les p'tits déj uniquement
pour les conducteurs et les conductrice
de poids lourd pour ces solitaires de la
route
le routier c'est un moment de
convivialité un moment de sociabilité un
moment d'humanité
c'est quand même plus intéressant aussi
de voir du monde le soir aussi parce
qu'on est quand même une bonne partie
entre 12 et 15 heures des relais au
volant
donc le soir c'est quand même bien
d'avoir quand même de rencontrer
d'autres personnes que le parisien paula
est conductrice de poids lourds
nationale elle part de nantes le lundi
revient à la maison le vendredi sans le
maintien des repas sur place le soir
elle n'aurait sans doute pas maintenu ce
rythme de travail
j'avais même eu l'idée de d'arrêter
partira la semaine et partir plus à la
journée et de rentrer le soir chez moi
s'il y avait rien d'ouvert même au
niveau des sanitaires tout ça c'est
encore plus difficile pour une femme
depuis 1999 qu'elle a repris la faire
avec françois patricia vie en 2020 ses
premières restrictions d'ouverture sur
place le soir mais uniquement emporté le
midi c'est double de travail pour
l'équipe des platanes moi je pense aussi
aux ouvriers le midi les ouvriers le
midi eux ça a remporté il mange dans
leur camionnette au froid parce qu'ils
n'ont pas forcément de
de chauffage dans leur camionnette quoi
pour nous par contre c'est encore pire
parce que autant à emporter on était
calé c'était tout le monde
les barquettes les les boîtes on
individuelle et c'est que là le midi
c'est d'une façon le soir sans et d'une
autre les platanes établissement à
vendre mais qui ne connaît pas les
stricts fermeture administrative en
période de confinement ce sera peut-être
un des arguments pour trouver de futurs
repreneurs